sa présence au tournoi des six nations
ce physique la technique c'est
maintenant bien vous pensez que je vais
vous parler de rugby
eh bien non parlons dont sportives et
les jolies la tonte de moutons c'est un
sport officielle en nouvelle zélande au
royaume uni et en australie
le but tondre des moutons le plus
rapidement possible et tout comme au
rugby il y a le tournoi des six nations
mais aussi une coupe du monde et tout
comme au rugby deviner qu'ils sont les
meilleurs
et oui les néo zélandais parole du
champion de france 1989 la technique
française à la technique et oser leur
baisse ne sont pas les mêmes c'est ici
on s'efforce de dissimuler au maximum
mais c'est pas facile
sur les 17 premiers championnats du
monde la nouvelle-zélande a remporté le
concours de tonte à la machine par
équipes
treize fois chez nos maîtres à penser un
petit bâton dans les années passent et à
chaque compétition internationale les
néo-zélandais sont loin devant exemple
en 1997 le coup de tondeuse de paul
kelly letondeur néo zélandais des
rapides au monde capable de tondre huit
moutons en 11 minutes 0,7 en 2011 c'est
encore un néo zélandais qui remporte le
tournoi international des compétitions
tout le temps en nouvelle zélande peut
être deux ou trois par semaine
c'est ce qui nous rend meilleurs mais
bon joueur les français en leur public
c'est pas de la tonte dollars c'est
regarder la même heure le geste toutes
magnifiques pour la première fois en
2019 la coupe du monde de tonte est
organisé en france et peut-être que les
tondeurs français feront mieux que
l'équipe de rugby tricolore
[Musique]